comme un sentiment de fermeté en ce
début de semaine à la cour pénale
internationale de la haye cette
impression la salle la doit à la
procureur fatou bensouda qui a demandé
un procès en appel à la suite d
acquittement de laurent gbagbo et
charles blé goudé en janvier 2019
les deux ex dirigeants ivoiriens sont
accusés d'avoir perpétré des massacres
en 2010 et 2011
lors des violences post électorales qui
avaient coûté la vie à trois mille
personnes
les deux hommes avaient été reconnus non
coupables de crimes contre l'humanité
par erreur la chambre de première
instance a commis une erreur en
acquittant monsieur gbagbo et monsieur
blé goudé en violation de ses
obligations fondamentales au titre de
l'article 74 5 vs
c'est fait et d'autres faits objectifs
vont tous dans le même sens
la majorité n'a pas achevé l'exercice de
raisonnement complet requis par
l'article 74
au moment où elle a été acquittée
oralement en janvier 2019
des auditions partiellement virtuel en
raison de la crise sanitaire lié aux
coronavirus les juges ont entamé un
délibéré pour savoir si un procès en
appel doit bien avoir lieu
le seul moyen selon les victimes de ces
crises ivoiriennes que justice soit
rendue mais rien n'est joué
primé l'issue possible nous étaient pas
les pattes d'un épisode le bambo ça
qu'il n'y ait pas le sud favorable
actuellement formulées par mme labelle
soudas est donc que le plus alors à
malabo dit charles blé goudé soit qui
plus est gagné là
la côte d'ivoire d'un autre côté à la
possibilité aussi que la cour estime que
la demande formulée par madame des
ressources des recevable et donc il ya
pensé un appel ce qui mènerait à bord
pendant longtemps de leurs abonnés sont
déjà bien roulé mais voilà c'est plus
aucun délai n'étant imposée à la chambre
d'appel de la cpi
les deux hommes vont devoir attendre
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
avant de connaître leur sort
une situation qui laisse planer le doute
sur la date de leur retour en côte
d'ivoire mais aussi leur participation à
la prochaine présidentielle